c'est vrai ce n'est pas grave contre le
virus comme l'indiquent nos ministes
avec son mii prix habituel c'est une
grève pour exiger l'arrêt des protocoles
le ton est donné devant la préfecture
des yvelines à versailles directeur
d'école et professeurs du premier et
second degré se sont réunis à 11 heures
ce jeudi 13 janvier ils manifestent leur
colère face au protocole sanitaire mis
en place par le gouvernement et
notamment par le ministre jean michel
blanquer on a un ministre qui nous
méprisent de plus en plus fin qui est
complètement déconnecté des réalités
on à moi je suis en lice et donc c'est
particulièrement le bac qui est
en jeu la pour les élèves qui qui
stresse face à
l'épreuve qui approche des absences
perlé pour un bon nombre d'élèves pour
un certain nombre de profs aussi on
demande de l' écoute on demande que les
réalités des établissements et des
écoles soient vraiment prise en compte
sur les risques sanitaires interne et
que de toute façon hier un partage une
analyse partagée et ça n'est pas le cas
c'est uniquement descendants sans tenir
compte de ce que disent les personnels
qui vivent le quotidien dans dans les
écoles et les établissements dans la
foule il n'y avait pas que le corps
enseignant qui manifestaient des élus
étaient également présents pour les
soutenir ce mouvement d'aujourd'hui il a
un caractère tout à fait inédit vous
avez l'ensemble des syndicats
enseignants qui se sont réunis les
parents d'élèves et nous collectivités
nous sommes directement impactés par ce
qui se passe dans les écoles vous le
savez bien puisque ça relève d'une
compétence des communes donc je suis
totalement solidaire bien entendu de ce
mouvement de grève ils étaient environ
300 à battre le pavé leurs
revendications allaient au delà de la
crise sanitaire c'est aussi une grève
qui qui veut faire la lumière sur le
manque de moyens et si on en est là
aujourd'hui c'est les écoles et les
lycées les collèges sont en train de
craquer c'est aussi parce que depuis le
début du quinquennat quinquennat macron
les moyens n'ont cessé de diminuer
qu'ils soient insuffisants et donc la
maintenance et ça craque c'est que ça
fait longtemps en fait qu' on est au
bord de la rupture le taux de
participation à la grève s'élève à 33 %
selon l'académie de versailles soit un
professeur sur deux pour les enseignants
du premier degré